تداعيات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بات
تهدد الملاحه الجويه المدنيه عالميا هذا
ما فهم من اخر بيان لوزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه حذرت فيه من ان الاسلحه الغربيه
التي تصل الى اوكرانيا باتت تنتشر في جميع
انحاء العالم خاصه في مناطق النزاعات
الاقليميه الاخرى وتنتقل الى يد المجرمين
والارهابيين والمتطرفين حسب ما جاء في
البيان هذه الاشارات سبق وان بعث بها
المندوب الروسي الا لدى الامم المتحده
ان روسيا منذ فتره طويله كانت تلفت
الانتباه الى ان تزويد نظام كييف بالاسلحه
سيؤدي الى وقوعها في ايدي المنظمات
الاجراميه والارهابيين والان هذا امر مؤكد
بالحقائق هذا ويذكر ان دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي قامت بتوريد مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 65 مليار يورو حسب تاكيد
الامين العام للناتو ينسى ستوتنبر في
الثالثه ابريل الجيري وبلغ حجم المساعده
العسكريه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا اكثر 35
مليار دولار اما في موسكو فيواصل الكرملين
بعد رسائله لخصومه الغربيين هذه المره من
خلال الاعلان عن اجراء تجربه ناجحه لاطلاق
صاروخ باليستي متقدم عابر للقارات بعد
اسابيعها على تعليق روسيا مشاركتها في اخر
اتفاق للحد من الاسلحه النوويه مع
الولايات المتحده هذا وحسب المراقبين يدخل
الاعلان ضمن التحذيرات المبطنه التي
يكررها الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بخصوص استخدامه اسلحه نوويه اذا تعرضت
روسيا للخطر